Speaker 1: I. I don't even know how to explain
this to you.
But there is yet another report that Donald
Trump has talked about fantasizing about sex
with his own daughter, Ivanka Trump.
And I know that there are people who may not
realize that this isn't new.
I told you about this a long time ago.
This is not a new thing.
Remember that clip I used to play where Trump
says, you know, if Evancho weren't my daughter,
perhaps I would be dating her.
And Trump on the Howard Stern Show talking
about his daughter as a piece of ass.
This is actually not new, but there is a new
report about it.
This is a this is an article from Newsweek.
Trump made shocking comments about Ivanka,
says an ex staffer.
These are claims from Miles Taylor.
Miles Taylor is the former Trump administration
official who wrote that scathing op ed about
Trump under the pen name Anonymous.
Taylor was a former chief of staff, is a former
chief of staff at the Department of Homeland
Security, and he describes a number of different
incidents in his forthcoming book, Blowback
where Trump Made Women Uncomfortable.
And the article says these incidents included
claims by aides that Trump made lewd comments
about his daughter, Ivanka's appearance, and
talked about what it might be like.
To have sex with her.
This prompted a rebuke from his own chief
of staff.
According to the book.
This is not.
There are a whole bunch of other examples.
This.
This is not new.
Okay, We have a clip here I'm going to play.
I'll just present the clip without comment.
But Trump's obsession with his own daughter
and his own daughter's body is not a new thing
to anybody who's been paying attention.
Speaker 2: What's the favorite thing you have
in common, Donald, with your daughter?
Speaker 3: Well, I was going to say sex, but
I can't relate that.
By the way, your daughter, she's beautiful.
Can I say this?
A piece of ass.
She looks more voluptuous than ever and actually
always been very voluptuous.
She's six feet tall.
She's got the best body she's had.
I've said that if Ivanka weren't my daughter,
perhaps I'd be dating her.
Speaker 1: So we're.
This is.
This is not normal.
This is weird.
It's extremely weird.
This.
This is sick.
It's sick.
Speaker 2: Woody Allen.
Speaker 1: People are clapping now and Yvonne
is clapping, but looks quite uncomfortable.
So listen, I mean, Trump's not fit to be president
regardless of this is the reality.
And I got dozens of emails about this half
saying, David, can you believe this crap?
Can you believe how sick this guy is?
And the other half saying this doesn't have
any bearing whatsoever.
If Trump's foreign policy was good, why would
he Why would we care that he finds his daughter
attractive?
My view is sort of in the middle in the sense
that regardless of his views about his daughter's
attractiveness, Trump is not fit to be president
of the United States.
In addition, this is so mind bendingly creepy
that it only furthers any normal person's
reaction that there's something the that.
What would we say?
The wheel is spinning but the hamster is dead.
Maybe is the phrase that I would use.
Something is very wrong with this guy.
And they talk about grooming and this, that
and the other thing.
This is borderline predatory behavior, but
very important, not new information.
And I know people people are already commenting.
And a couple wrote to me saying this is this
is just so ridiculous.
It's so not believable.
It's nothing like Trump.
This is just a corroboration of the type of
thing Trump has said five, six, seven times
in history.
It's disgusting.
I think we're going to move on from it and
leave it there.
Make sure you subscribe, by the way, on YouTube.
We have seen in the last 36 to 48 hours, maybe
thanks to Howard Stern's endorsement, a significant
acceleration in the fight for 2 million YouTube
subscribers.
Help us get there.
More than 3 million people in May watched
our YouTube clips and did not subscribe.
All I'm asking you is for something that's
free.
Just hit that subscribe button.
Let's get to 2 million.
Let's
do it, folks.